it's raining it's raining you see the
water on the glasses doesn't matter if
it's raining we still do the videos
anyway that's how we do hello everyone
welcome to another book update video
today's message is get some help you
know the bigger the project that you're
working on the more likely you're going
to need help and this is something that
man I need to constantly remind myself
of and I think as entrepreneurs we need
to constantly remind ourselves off
because we tend to jump all in we tend
to want to do everything ourselves we
tend to think nobody can help me this
has to be me you know nobody can do it
like I'm going to do it and that is
faulty thinking this is going to slow
you down because whatever your project
is the bigger it is the more you're
going to need people to help you up so
how this relates my book is I've been
I've been struggling with getting all
the content out and and feeling like I
got to do everything myself and putting
all this stress and pressure myself and
I felt like nobody can talk like me and
I've had this challenge my whole career
where I felt like nobody can write like
me one just the authenticity and to
getting the ideas out of my head a lot
of times I don't even know what I'm
going to say until I start writing and I
think better by writing than I do
talking's that's why I can't just record
a message and give it to somebody to
transcribe and put down for me so when
applying it to my book I felt like I got
to do everything myself and then I
realized hey you know what if I break
this down into smaller chunks there's a
lot of stuff that I don't actually have
to do myself I have a friend of mine
Jason Jason is helping me with some of
the titles and finding quotes and the
layout and adding new ideas and
basically making the book rise up I've
got another friend Jennifer who's
helping me with the writing and what I
realized is you know the book is a lot
about theory and then the practical
application how I've applied it's my
business but I also wanted to show how
it can apply to any business you don't
have to be Evan Carmichael for this to
work for you and throughout the book i'm
interviewing people who have between
50,000 and 150 million in revenue five
different companies and showing how they
have applied these strategies and to
show you that hey this can work for you
just as easy as it works for me and it
works for them no matter what size
you're in and so those parts of the book
I'm doing interviews with them and I'm
actually on my way right now to
interview someone and they're not my
words right and so Jenna that is a great
writer a great editor and she's going to
be with me on all the hangouts and all
the calls i do and recording and
transcribing and taking their words and
putting them into the book because it's
not my words being set and so it frees
me up frees up a lot of my time to help
me focus on the important parts of the
book that are my words my thoughts and
make that all the better so whatever
project you're working on find some help
don't try to do it yourself don't try to
think I'm the only one who could do this
find the parts that really truly only
you can do and then delegate outsource
automate eliminate the rest to help your
project rise up and help it get to where
it needs to go alright so question time
I always answer your questions every
week before that I'm super excited
because this week my contract came in
and I got three copies of the contract
and I signed them all and sent them back
I still have to send them back but
they're on their way soon and that's
great I'm going to get I'm assuming one
signed copy back from my records and
today normally I go and I right and I
walk to the starbucks but today I'm
doing an interview and I'm interviewing
sharing galore who's the founder of a
salsa company that I'm involved in
Toronto dance salsa one of north
america's largest sauce instruction
school will teach five to six thousand
people a year how to salsa dance and i'm
going to be interviewing her with jen of
course helping me out and add in her
content to the book and then next week
back on to writing mode so it's today is
book interview next week is book writing
okay on to the questions luckily this
time I brought the printed sheet I'm not
going back to Evernote to answer these
questions after last week's fiasco on
the video that got me upset pissed off
one of the downsides of recording with
an iPad what I realized is that
it stops recording I didn't notice so
I'm just answering questions and none of
them recorded because I was tabbing out
to go to the Evernote file I see them in
and then coming back so I'm pissed off I
don't want to answer them again right
now so into the questions here we go
first up dread dog when is your book
coming out thanks for the question bro I
appreciated all the great comments you
believe in on the videos the book has to
be submitted to penguin Random House by
October 15th that's my hard deadline I'm
hoping to obviously have it done before
that I always try to get under deadlines
and not go over and then it's planned to
be released next fall which seems like
an eternity and I know you guys are
waiting for the book and I wanted to be
out but that's the book publishing
industry and so in October fifteenth and
release next fall when is the beard
coming back haha just kidding no more
questions about the beard I got a bit of
scruff happening today but yeah my wife
will kill me if I bring that beard back
when is the book coming out and what
will you name it Jepsen a name would
include the word believe am I correct so
I answer the question but when in terms
of what the title hmm you know I'm going
to hold off on that I'm going to hold
off on answering that one for now but
yes believe is a core theme to the book
next up Tamara weeks who wrote in to say
I hope the man you interviewed can't
think of his name but he has a software
company and they work in teams and are
encouraged to bring the newborns to work
I hope he makes it into your book he's
one of my favorites you have interviewed
thanks Tamara his name was Richard
Sheridan from Mendel innovations the
book is called joy inc and yes i'll be
interviewing him he is in ann arbor
michigan and i'm heading down there at
the end of july i believe to go
interview him Nina's coming with me we
are taking the mini out and what she's
gonna go shopping and I am going to go
interview Richard next up site to go
hooray for the video when starting out
with your first book should you focus on
making the book as good as it can be or
just getting it out there as soon as
possible so you can get the necessary
feedbacks to reiterate the versions of
your book this is a great question and I
think it depends if you're working with
a publisher or not so the way that I'm
war
right now is I have my book with my
thoughts uh it's about two thirds done
I'd say and we transferred everything
into a Google Doc so that Jason and jen
and my team can review it with me and
can give feedback and suggestions along
the way I am pretty set in the content
but they have some ideas that they
contribute and help and make the pages
better maybe making points more clear
and so I find that process really helps
and once i'm done writing my draft of
the book we're basically to be going
through every page and have everybody
school or each page to make sure it hits
all the points that we want to hit a
certain process that i'm using i want
every page to be entertaining i find so
many books that you're reading through
and you know you're waiting for that
next chapter to end and and it's
frustrating and you know i find also
some books that I'm reading and then I
forgot what I was even reading that kind
of doze off while I'm reading have to go
back and read the same thing three or
four times and I don't want that to me
my book right I want people to be
engaged with the book and so we have
this criteria that we're using to score
every page on the book and I'm going to
score Jason's going to score Jen's going
to score and we're all happy with it
it's it's a done page and we move on so
that's kind of ongoing working with a
publisher they want to see a final
manuscript so I've sent my draft to them
and the editor there has some
interesting thoughts that we're
incorporating but for the most part she
wants to see it when it's done she's
gonna give me her thoughts and i'm
assuming part of that you know why does
it take a year for the book to come out
once i once i give it to them is because
there's some back and forth on it but
ideally they want to see a finished
product before they start working on it
just because they may have some thoughts
or ideas that that i was already
planning on addressing so that's how i'm
working it with my own team very
collaborative very just put it out there
start writing content getting feedback
and opinions and ideas and then to the
publisher final version and then working
from their feedback from there next up
sensei Ryan next week's video don't you
do like five videos a week just curious
do to your Q&A
on a set day of the week thanks sensei
Ryan thank you for all the comments
you're an awesome support of the channel
to answer the question I do 14 videos a
week bro 14 at least videos every week
to a day are coming up sometimes three
on a monday because i have my mastermind
that I do videos reply for and sometimes
more on a thursday when i'm doing
multiple hangers but it's a lot of work
it's a big schedule to keep up with but
definitely more than the five a week in
terms of this series it's always out on
the weekend i record it on the Tuesday
because Tuesday is my writing day so I'm
you know usually walking to my starbucks
recording and answering your questions
flip it to Christina who's my editor who
puts it all together and then we release
it on the weekend next up eleni Presley
I need to write my books Evan do you
have a system I can follow that works
best and any ideas how to get a book
deal or published online I think for
some people it comes really naturally
and some people need more time to think
about it I'm definitely the latter I
need to think about it it doesn't just
come and what I basically done is you
have to have a message right so I've
been helping entrepreneurs for over a
decade and answering their questions and
taking our feedback and over that
process have come up with a number of my
own strong opinions on how businesses
should be run and I've applied them to
my companies and I've helped other
people and so I have a methodology
that's what I'm sharing basically in the
book and so if you're writing the book
you know you got to figure out what your
methodology is what you staying for why
it's important what message you had that
you want to share with the world is
going to make the world a better place
somehow so that's a start then in terms
of writing it everybody has their own
style I guess for me I block off
tuesdays and fridays tuesdays is mostly
my writing day or in this case doing
interviews and then fridays i'm
reviewing thoughts and comments from my
team and looking at how that might
improve the book so far we're on a good
track if if i'm running a little late if
we're punching up against that deadline
that might add an extra day but I find
with book writing or any really big kind
of thinking project you can't just do it
an hour
time at least I can't i find it takes me
like half an hour to an hour just to get
back into what i was writing before and
so I need a whole day I need that I need
to have a whole day blocked off not
doing anything else not worrying about
other projects not doing interviews or
calls or anything else just like this
for example right I'm going to go
interview Sharon that won't take the
whole day I don't think maybe it will
look s we'll see but you know I may have
an hour two at the end of that i'm not
going to start writing because it's not
enough time for me and so I find that
blocking out entire chunks of days and
doing less so you know two days per week
instead of you know for half days per
week I find works better for me and I
encourage you to try out different
styles so it works for you in terms of
the publisher I think it really depends
on what your goal is my goal anything
that I do is I wanted to have a huge
impact wanna be able to reach millions
of people and I don't care about a book
right I don't need to have a book to say
that hey I'm a published author and I'm
put that on my book I don't I don't I
don't care about that I don't need to
feed the ego on that and it used to be
much more important than it is today I
can open up almost any door just with my
youtube channel and my website right now
where before you need to have a book to
say hey I'm a published author that
gives you credibility I have enough
credibility and so I was only going to
write it if I gotta deal with a major
publisher and I got their backing and
their commitment in the form of a
substantial upfront payment if that
wasn't going to happen then I wasn't
interested in it you know I had
publishers reach out to me for years
saying hey we could do a book but there
was no commitment from them there was no
advance and I felt like it would be all
on me and I wouldn't get any resources
or help and that wasn't what I was
interested in and so the process I went
through was I got a agent who then
introduced me to a literary agent and
she set up meetings with a whole bunch
of different publishers we created a
quick overview of what the book was
going to be about in the sample chapter
sent it off to a whole bunch of
different publishers and then my agent
Nina
lined up a whole bunch of meetings for
me i think we had like six or seven
meetings over two days all kind of back
to back to back and let me get to know
the publishers let them ask me questions
as well so i went both ways and then
they put in kind of competing offers and
i went with penguin Random House which
was a great offer and also got a good
vibe from from the editor there and
connected with a fellow kind of speaker
expert who had gone with that same
editor and publisher and and he had only
great things to say so that kind of gave
me the confidence to move forward so
that's my process again it would start
with what's your goal you just want to
have a book and say hey I did a book or
just something to tell your grandkids
that look at my book then you could just
sell publish and put it online and just
go for it if you want to have a big
impact and really get it out there I
would look at how can I get partnered up
with the publisher is going to help me
get some distribution of it so that's it
i'm almost at toronto day and salsa I'm
gonna do my interview with Sharon hope
you guys like this video if you have
questions for me about
wait for that truck to pass
if you have questions for me about my
book or the book writing process
anything that can help you leave in the
comments below and I will answer in next
week's edition thank you guys for
watching keep believing and I will see
you soon